[Music]
hey what's up you guys what's up
we were just reliving the moment on the
live stream yesterday when pookie
knocked baby yoda killed baby yoda and
then laid down next to him on her back
like yeah did that [ __ ]
she was chilling out with him
i think she thought she was in trouble
because that was like sit there
trying to play it off oh my god yeah tom
said we should lift that out
there and like use it as a commercial
yeah maybe we should that is pretty
[ __ ] funny that she was farting right
back there doing that [ __ ]
yeah all right so uh if you were
uh one of our patrons they're you know
that
i got into it about the thing about old
boy you know what i mean
like we're supposed to be doing the
movie review for it this week but
uh it disappeared off all the streaming
services yeah so
basically so i ordered a dvd but i don't
think it's gonna get here in time so
we recorded another movie review to have
a backup
but then dominic one of our patrons said
hey here's um
this app called be flicks where you can
watch it for free
so i'm going to try that out on the xbox
later and if we can watch it for free
then we'll do a review
of that so you might get two movie
reviews this week we will eventually do
old boy if i can't watch it on there but
i just have to wait till the dvd arrives
and i don't think it's coming until
monday
even though i ordered it and it's like
supposedly in jacksonville which is only
like
a couple miles away from well a couple
miles it's probably like 50 miles away
from here i could drive up there and get
it in the time there's
about whatever um so yeah so i'm just
saying
might be one movie review might be two
we'll we'll see how it goes
so uh this uh documentary here
we found this last night we were just
like
scrolling through [ __ ] and uh what was
it amazon prime right
yeah we're on like the free to me little
thing and i said hey it's only an hour
and five minutes and it's about hh homes
yeah so uh you know we did a show on
jenny's she's pretty well versed and i'd
forgotten a lot about h.h homes i forgot
what i said about him
it was a long time ago we did that show
yeah that was a while back but we're
watching this
documentary and it was actually a pretty
good documentary
it was kind of factual you know it kind
of stuck to the facts
but it's funny because all it was is
what jenny does just set to a bunch of
damn stock footage that dude
well yeah the thing about it and you
ought to just make your own damn [ __ ]
documentaries and sell that [ __ ] to
[ __ ] amazon prime
yeah you probably have you probably have
all the video editing stuff to do it
yeah i could do it well that's the thing
i will say that this
i looked this cup what haven't you made
on that this has a five
percent rating on rotten tomatoes i
don't like it and everybody basically
said this is the most amateurish yeah
it's like it looks like worse than what
high school kids can make yeah the thing
that i don't
i don't have a problem with using stock
footage for stuff or using
especially something about hh homes
where there's like you know a lot of
archival like photos and [ __ ]
and you have to fill in the [ __ ] somehow
but the problem is that all the stock
that a lot of the stock footage they
used didn't have buckle to do with
anything they were talking about yeah
that was the problem
i think that was kind of like and when
they had like reenactments of like
murders like
you know and stuff like that it's like
it was all like modern
people it was so you could tell that
they had got it from
a stock footage site right and just kind
of
wove it all together and i will say that
a lot of this script too like when i
went back and read like the wikipedia
page for hh homes he took a lot of he
was right from wikipedia right from
wikipedia it's like he probably made 4
or 5 000 from that though he's not
reading it like directly from wikipedia
but i did notice that some of the turns
of phrase that he used were right off of
the wikipedia page
so i will say that it's an hour and five
minutes it seemed
much longer weirdly because it seemed
like the last
10 or 15 minutes of it he kind of went
into
the theory that you know hh homes was
jack the ripper which like i said it's i
think it's [ __ ] he thinks it's
[ __ ] too
there's really no proof of it um you
know h.h holmes was demonstrably in the
u.s when some of the murders were taking
place in the uk
um and also now this it did give me some
information that i didn't actually know
because i hadn't been on the wikipedia
page for a while
but i guess they exhumed h.h holmes's
body
in 2017 because wasn't there kind of
like some rumor about
how that he wasn't dead like he faked
his own death or some [ __ ] like that i'm
like
yeah i mean they said he was well
preserved too his mustache was a
mustache i'm like of course [ __ ] yeah
his bowler had i don't think they buried
him with the bowler hat but um but yeah
so
i will just say that right from there so
i wouldn't recommend
i mean h.h holmes is a fascinating dude
and there's like all kind of
really good books and [ __ ] about i'm
probably devil and white city is the
best one
um oh but the one by uh what's that
dude's name harold schechter
what the [ __ ] is the name of that book i
just read it not too long ago but it was
uh america's first year was that no it
was called depraved that's what it's
called i know i'd remember
um that book is also excellent this like
i said this just seemed
like i don't want to [ __ ] on the dude
too much what's the dude's name philip
gardner yeah
he wrote and directed it i enjoyed it it
was yeah
yeah yeah i understood what it was i
understood what i was seeing
yeah yeah it's just i had i had some
kind of problem it just looked really
really
cheap and really really i wish that he
would have tried harder
to make the stock footage at least
fit what he was talking about yeah and
he you reused a lot of stuff and i will
say too that you could tell particularly
when it got toward the end
he kept like repeating himself or saying
the same thing like in different ways
you could tell he was trying to like pat
it out
to an hour yeah um because he just kept
like repeating
he's trying to pat it out without making
it sound like commentary
but yeah i gotta get i'll give him this
this is the kind of thing you didn't
have we'd have to pay for it to see it
it was the kind of thing or where you'd
sit back you you could sit back and just
listen to it like an audio book
which i would recommend yeah because the
like i see it look watching it is
the
pretty much nothing and uh well he's
just trying to set a tone
yeah you could tell you know it didn't
it didn't cost anything to make
uh his voice his narration is good
though and uh yeah
british british guy yeah and his uh
the the content is factual you know yeah
it is true what he's saying and i like
the fact that
he tried to he tried to divide
um fact from fiction because there's a
lot of mythic elements to
h.h homes all right it's been a long
time since we did the show
i remembered walking away from the
holmes case as
kind of disappointed that he wasn't
quite what he was cracked up to be
um a lot of what they s what i had
believed about him
prior to doing the show like he killed
200 something people and that that
was a functioning hotel a lot of that
wasn't true no it wasn't
exaggerated very exaggerated and i think
even the murder castle the way i
pictured it was kind of exaggerated i
mean
he did have some gas pipes that went to
certain rooms that he could control from
his room
there were some shoots that would go
down to the basement
there was stuff like candy there was
stuff that was like racks like torture
type racks
but from what i remember the case he
doesn't mention it in this one but
when i remember the case there there was
no evidence that stuff was ever used
i think he mentioned it well i think he
mentioned it in this documentary in the
sense that
i don't know i think that torture stuff
in there i think that was a later
extrapolation
the thing about it though is that i
think a lot of hh homes and i'm not
saying that h.h holmes wasn't a serial
killer
that he wasn't he was yeah um but much
like henry lee lucas if that's not too
weird a comparison to make
um he really kind of fed into his own
legend
well a lot of the um myth that surrounds
him came from his own mouth
like his confessions because some of the
newspapers back then paid him like 7 500
which was a good ton of money back then
uh for his story and like all this
and they knew that some of it at least
was [ __ ] because he confessed to
killing what 27 people and then like
some of these people they found out were
still alive
yeah and like some of the people that he
was rumored to have killed were also
still alive and it's like they have
records of them dying like
old age like many years later he was
more like a con man
yeah and a black widow he would kill a
lot of wives a black widower
black widower he'd kill his wives and
common men seemed to do that
there were several cases from from the
1800s
where guys were doing that for insurance
money remember yeah there were some
women doing that too there were women
doing it never guys doing it
because you could get away with it
easier back then so
he was one of those now some so two
little boys disappeared
or so they think two little boys
disappeared
they were hanging out with them and they
just where'd they go he said they went
back to their parents
nobody knows what happened to him but
nobody knows who they were they might be
alive
they might have lived you don't know
it was just a lot of he lied a lot
and he never he never said that he
killed those boys but he died
but he admitted to killing a whole bunch
of people that he didn't kill
yeah and uh he was selling skeletons
that came from mysterious places i think
those were some of the ex-wives
or the wives yeah and like i said it's
perfectly possible because some of the
stuff about the murder castle like the
stuff about
um you know like i said the the shoots
and they did find like an oven in there
that was like
crematorium there was like a crematorium
in the bottom so obviously he was up to
some nefarious [ __ ] in there
um but there was a real deep pit that
had a bunch of lie in it and they never
figured out what was in that down in
there yeah i guess they didn't have the
technology back then to
go down in a real deep pit and try to
find out i guess they figured it'd all
be
it would all be just dissolved anyway
and they weren't
nowadays they'd go down there and try to
get as much as they could but back in
the 1800s like oh [ __ ] it just cover it
up
there's a bunch down in there that's
just the thinking of the time it's a
bunch it's it's
too hard i ain't going down there yeah
[ __ ] that yeah too dangerous our lives
are rough enough yeah
well it's just funny to think that you
know the forensic technology that we
have now
you know as flawed as it is it's like
back then they didn't have that it's
like they didn't even really have
fingerprinting until the late 19th
century
that wasn't even a thing yeah so it's
like it's pretty much no fingerprint
database either
yeah and it's like it's kind of like
well if you wanted to get caught for a
crime they basically had to see you do
it
i mean pretty much yeah or you had to
have enough witnesses come forward and
said you did it and then they'd be like
yeah i suppose you did
whether you did or not maybe there's a
bunch of people that don't like you
because you could frame somebody easily
yeah big time too you know it went both
ways
justice was real it was even less
reliable than it is today in the united
states and i would say justice is
unreliable in the united states if
you're being tried you're going to be
found guilty about 90
of the times over that well i think
people have
to because you're guilty people have
well but i mean
also people have a tendency to that if
you got
arrested then you did something then you
must have done something
most of it's pretty uh open and closed
though
yeah on video yeah or they had a lot of
witnesses and that you know that was his
weapon
and the thing about it and like i talked
about this before because this was
something that i kind of brought up when
i was
uh when i was writing my uh faceless
villain books
is that a lot is has been made of the
fact that
you know in i think up to like 1967 or
something like that
uh you know the the rate of
conviction for murders was much much
higher than it is nowadays
and people are like oh why are people
getting away with stuff nowadays like
you know when the forensics are so much
better but i don't know if that's
necessarily what that says
i think it means that prior to the
forensics being good
um a lot more innocent people got put in
jail
so it's like that they said you know
they just got a conviction that doesn't
mean that that person actually did it
yeah i mean because a lot of times they
couldn't
exclude him from the case or you know
right so therefore he might have done it
so he did that's what i mean so it's
like so i kind of feel like
you know it sounds bad when you say it's
like oh there's a lot less
you know we don't solve as many murders
there aren't as many convictions
nowadays as there were back then
but i think in some ways i don't know if
that's the case but i suspect
that it's because a lot more innocent
people because it was easier to like
jail somebody for because like i said
they couldn't do dna or anything like
that
they were just like well all these
people said they saw you do it so i
guess you did it bye
a lot of the problems in the u.s court
system though isn't so much the trial or
the evidentiary
parts of the of the cases it's it's
sentencing
the judge's hands are kind of tied
he can't give a sentence that fits the
[ __ ] crime a lot of times he has
mandatory minimums he has to do
which that can be pretty brutal yeah or
like i don't really think this is you
know
judge might be in a situation where i
don't really think
you know this is what it's made out to
be but it did occur with a firearm and
that
that's a minimum of 10 years so you get
10 years you know i'd like to give you
two years but
no i got to give you 10. [ __ ] like that
yeah you know
well yeah it is kind of stupid because
some people get like ridiculously long
sentences for something that's like
yeah that's like not even a violent
crime for example uh which
i think is dumb it's you know if if no
violence is committed
in the course of the crime i think they
should like go a lot easier on you so
they can have a lot more room for people
that do do horrible [ __ ]
but the thing about it is that hh homes
one i you know i kind of like like i
said this documentary it's not a great
documentary it's very very
cheap um you know like i said the
narration is fine
it's back there and it was factual yeah
it was fine to watch seemed a little
like i said it was only like an hour
long but it seemed much longer i guess
because it kind of repeated itself i
looked at it like a podcast
yeah i suppose falcats with a visual
element
it's probably better to just listen to
it like it's gonna do it yeah like a
little audio book
yeah don't don't watch the visuals
because like i said half of people will
at more actually more than half the time
like eighty percent of the time it
doesn't have anything to do with what
they're talking about
it's just some random [ __ ] hey we
have uh some
stock footage of an old city from the
19th century that was the best part
though
yeah that was kind of cool or like we or
we had like this old silent movie like
an old like comedy or something and they
put it in there
we'll put that in there it's like it
didn't have anything to do with anything
but um yeah have a good footage somebody
was filming from a uh i guess it was a
primitive automobile
and i don't know what city it was but
the [ __ ] main street was super wide
with buildings that are now long gone
you look at them it almost looks like
ancient rome
yeah you had horse-drawn carriages and
it was quite
kind of long and then you'd look and you
go hey man that's a car and there'd be a
little putt-putt car next to it
and what was struck me is that i didn't
realize it but those
i guess it was a model a it might have
been model a's
they would they were going the same
speed
as the horse-drawn carriages yeah and no
rules to the road they're just going
over there's all over the place
people walking in front horse walking in
front so the very early cars went the
same
speed as a horse drawn carriage or the
horse is just trotting
so just like damn i didn't realize that
they were that slow but yeah i guess
yeah it's like what's the [ __ ] point
of it 25 might have been a top
speed well it was it was a horse's
carriage is what what the thinking was
yeah it didn't have to be faster than a
carriage and you had to
work where could you go yeah you'd just
be running into horses all day
so it's just a horse's carriage yeah
maybe it was just like hey it's a car
where you don't have to clean a horse
poop after and you don't have to
eat it yeah some of this newfangled
stuff called gasoline
wow it may have been electric
some of those early cars were electric i
think they were a lot of people don't
know that
the electric and internal combustion
cars first generation were about neck
and neck
it was just a gasoline one out over time
because you didn't have to
it didn't take time to charge you just
put fluid in it yeah ready to go
which you know everybody wants that like
it was instant gratification
gratification that's what i was going to
say yeah they didn't burn much fuel they
were pretty fuel efficient
yeah didn't make much power either but
they didn't have to and they never broke
they weren't running under any damn
stress
well and back in those days too it's not
like they had [ __ ] interstate
highways
so it's kind of like you just had to
park along yeah yeah
you know like faster than walking yeah
faster than
you have to worry about horses faster
than the bike well i don't know if it
was faster than a bicycle
i'd have bicycles in there with them
they were going to same speed
i didn't really realize that it was that
and i was watching and it was kind of
amazing because it wasn't that far
removed from ancient roman technology
yeah
the only thing that was removed from
ancient rome was that internal
combustion car but it really wasn't
that much better than that horse-drawn
carriage when you looked at it
true about the same i think romans had
probably tripped over that bicycle
though
they didn't have bicycles they would
have thought that that was [ __ ] great
that was a horse you didn't have to feed
yeah a man-powered horse
i have often said that in the in the
event of a zombie apocalypse
i think a bicycle would be a bicycle and
a sword
yeah yep don't need no gas
don't need no ammo yeah like a
variable gear that's what i'm doing like
bmx type bike or a mountain type bike
yeah
saddlebags on it you can carry guns yeah
yeah in your kit
yeah i like it you can put your backpack
on it i'll put them up on a handle and a
sword holster like [ __ ] sword because
they don't call it a holster what do
they call that a sword
scabbers i knew that was starting with a
s
but yeah so the thing about h.h holmes
like i said i like that they kind of
that he kind of went into the whole jack
the ripper thing because i only heard i
guess that was kind of a thing
like a few years back um and i think it
was like
why didn't [ __ ] holmes's
great-great-great-grandson or some [ __ ]
like that
uh because he had a couple kids and they
had they ended up pretty normal because
he had a bunch of wives that he was
married to like at
the same time i think he had three of
them at the same time but i don't know
if
any of them knew about each other or if
he'd killed some of them or i don't know
they don't they haven't figured that out
but um i think that his great great
grandson or his
great-great-great-grandson
got the idea that uh you know oh maybe
he was
he went over to the u he popped over the
uk to do the [ __ ]
jack ripper killings and um i don't know
it seemed like that was kind of a thing
where they just wanted to sell some
books because you know jack the ripper
he slapped the ripper killings were
nothing like a holmes killing they're
not steaming
um holmes seemed more an opportunistic
kind of he was more of a con man type of
dude like i said he wanted to
when he killed somebody he wanted to get
something out of it like he wanted to do
like insurance fraud or he wanted to
sell their skeleton or both
um you know he even tried to like fake
his own death didn't he until i get
and and what's weird is that uh you know
he killed little kids when they when
little kids came
became inconvenient yeah he gassed three
of them in the chest
and there's no evidence or even any
insinuation that he kept him for sex or
anything
there didn't seem to be any indication
that he had a
problem getting girlfriends so sex
wasn't the motive there i don't think
there was a sexual motive with holmes
it really doesn't seem like it he just
seems a more just a psychopath
sociopathic dude that needed money and
he gives about money more than anything
else i think
yeah because when he was building the
murder castle i mean
one of his things was that he would have
all these like contractors in there to
to build [ __ ] and then he would just
like not
pay them yeah and he was a pathological
liar yeah
which leads me away from kind of like
the sexual psychopath to more than just
the [ __ ] sociopath
pathological liar thief and he he
he killed women and children and men and
men too he just killed whoever
when it when they became inconvenient
or when there was an opportunity to make
money so there's no
sexuality in any of this which leads me
to believe
there probably wasn't any torture either
because usually
when a serial killer is sexually
motivated that's when the torture comes
in
well yeah because they want to see the
fear and they want to see the pain on
the other person's because they get off
on it
h.h holmes just mostly seemed like he
was a very
i know this is going to sound [ __ ] up
but he was a very practical yeah
killer he was just trying to get you out
of the way and they he wanted like
your insurance money or he wanted your
skeleton but with
little fuss yeah so he's like i'm just
gonna like take their
money and i'm just gonna dump him in
this oven and nobody's gonna like ever
hear from him he had those little girls
and he didn't torture him or rape him
which
a a real serial killer probably would
have um
so i just don't think that there was uh
he he wasn't
the sadistic type of serial killer that
he was
that they wanted to portray him as like
he had
things that they called torture racks
evidently in the media
but i remember hearing that there was no
evidence that
any of that [ __ ] was used and that they
weren't really torture racks
they were more like things that that
they used to use back then
to straighten out spines and to be like
a chiropractor
yeah and he was a doctor so he might
have had
something like that i mean maybe it was
just kind of like morgue tables that's
how he used to like [ __ ]
you know come straight and do things and
[ __ ] like that because like i said he
was real big on like selling people's
skeletons to medical right
so he might have been rendering turning
people into into into anatomical
skeletons
for sale that's yeah and they might have
misunderstood what it was they were
seeing
it might have been the equipment that he
was using to process bodies
turn him turn them into these yeah
because everything
seemed kind of geared toward that just
like oracle's saying a very
goal-oriented killer yeah it's just kind
of like
you know in a lot of ways and this is
weird i might have brought this up on
another one but what this is something
that you see with a lot of
female serial killers particularly
poisoners um
they either do it because of like
munchausen syndrome or some [ __ ] like
that or
they do it for this reason where it's
just kind of like they they want
insurance money
and they're just trying to get you out
of the way you know like belle gunness
did something like that where
she was just like putting um you know
ads in the paper for like hey i need a
husband and i have all this land and
stuff and they would come out there and
she'd whack him in the head and bury him
on the [ __ ] thing
and he would you know take their money
and it seems like
he's more that type of dude yeah and
they would say that he had
the house all made up like a maze and
all these [ __ ]
he did have some weird [ __ ] going on
like rooms that
you could lock people into like cells
and they had
gas pipes that went to them but that
might have also just been part of his
processing scam
you checked somebody and it didn't seem
evidently this stuff
had not really been used because it was
never open to the public
yeah because it was three stories right
the first story was like
with shops like a pharmacy and [ __ ] and
then the second story was like
uh apartments or some kind of living
then the hotel bart was on the third
floor but i don't think it was ever open
to the public or even like completely
finished
so i think he had this plan where where
once um
once he had it open to the public
he could take select people where he
needed the skeletons and assign him
into a room and then lock him into that
room
all right when he checked him in and
then go over to his room and turn the
gas on and gasp
yeah so he cause he did have that he had
like a panel where he could like gas
rooms it
well that kind of infers that he's not
into [ __ ]
combat he's not turned on by fighting
these people he's not turned on by
torturing them or raping them it's a
process he just walked him into that
room and locked him
and they're like what the [ __ ] is going
on you know they're they're unpacking
their [ __ ] yeah it was just like a weird
one
here you know what i mean he's going
over there turning the gas off
yeah that's the sign of a dude who
doesn't want any jam trouble
yeah he's just he just wants the
envelope like i said he just wants the
body
either because he wants the insurance
money or he wants to sell your skeleton
right which i'm not saying that makes it
better that story doesn't sell as well
though yeah it's a lot i mean you know
it is a lurid
yeah i mean it is pretty horrifying that
like some crazy [ __ ] would
construct an entire thing with that kind
of [ __ ] in it that's scary enough but
what the newspapers were trying to sell
what was the idea that he would lure
beautiful young women onto that floor
and
chase them around maze-like
warrens and then lock them in there and
eventually gas
them but that doesn't seem like what he
was doing no
it was a lot more simple than that the
real process of them
was weird that he had going to several
rooms that way he could
keep him go he could get several
families at once
which yeah that's pretty or take out a
whole family if you wanted to
well that wouldn't cost anything it's
just pipes and valves
yeah you know and he did have a thing
where he would hire like certain
contractors to do one
part and then like he didn't want
anybody to see the entire plans
obviously because it was like
this is in the time of gas lamps though
so that was normal that's true
so it wouldn't have been super weird it
wouldn't have been super weird it just
didn't have a fixture there or whatever
ken said do you think he made
lye soap with the corpse fat um you know
what if that seems like something he
would probably well it seems like he
wouldn't want to waste any of it you
know what i mean because like if he
wants to sell the skeleton you might as
well make [ __ ] with the rest of the body
too it's like [ __ ]
you know yeah it seems like soap would
be the easiest thing it's like because i
was thinking oh you could make like
leather shirt with the skin but that
seems like too much trouble
based on what that's pretty easy to do
when i remember though he was making a
lot of money
just by ordering things on credit and
reselling them and then not
not yeah he did that kind of [ __ ] too or
he would rent
things and sell them you'd rent it under
a false id
and then then sell them yeah um yeah
he wasn't into uh nickel and dime [ __ ]
like let's make some
soap that probably wouldn't have been
enough money he liked to make
thousands at once yeah you know so he he
cut he was going for big scores
i think the selling of the skeletons
made sense because
one you could get rid of somebody two
the skeleton was worth
quite a bit back then for the medical
and if you took out an insurance policy
on that person that was like
two paydays right you could you know get
the money from their skeleton and you
get the money
and then you're disposing of the body
all in one thing it's win-win
when when when you're disposing the body
afterwards instead of burying it
you collect on it and then you you don't
bury it you turn it into a scalp and
sell it
yeah and it's you know so you're
profiting it off of the [ __ ] evidence
too
yeah he was working all the angles he's
working all these different angles kevin
donovan said yeah read the book the
devil in white city it is very very good
um
i do recommend it and like i said there
was another but one by harold schechter
called depraved which is also very good
um although i kind of feel i haven't
read it in a while but i kind of feel
like that
leaned more into like the whole murder
castle like the myth about it
um which like i said i think a lot of
that's kind of been debunked he did have
that
but it wasn't quite as lurid as it
seemed like
i think it's like belle gunness yeah
dude like that never you call it
how you say your name yeah i think he
was a guy he was a guy that was kind of
like
that yeah she was just like i said
female serial killers like a female
tend to be very practical in the sense
that they're not it's not a sexual
motive it's not anything like that it's
that's very vanishingly rare
most the time when women kill a bunch of
[ __ ] it's because she wants the
money
yeah and what's weird is that um i had
the feeling
people would he kept showing up these
boys
and then the boys would vanish that
happened twice and it was enough
to where people asked him about it and
he disappeared
i have a feeling that he may have been
gay
okay um and
he just saw women as a means to get
money
you know yeah that's possible so i don't
so and
and he might have had kind of a
personality a little bit more female so
when he
became a serial killer he was more like
a female serial killer
you know what i mean yeah the motives
and the the motive and the style is
similar
it's weird though i do kind of feel like
you saw more of these sort of practical
serial killers both male and female um
in like the late 19th century because
there were a lot of like you know women
poisoners or a lot of dude poisoners
that were just like poisoning wives and
friends and what was doing that kind of
yeah like doing that kind of fraud
well it's like i guess back then it was
like super easy to just
one to just you know give a fake name on
something and everybody's like suppose
so
um but also you could take out life
insurance on other people without them
knowing about it
and then you could just like bump him
off and be like oh my goodness well i
i think he was i i kind of think he was
gay
and uh so really didn't mean anything to
him as a
as a as a psychopathic serial killer to
marry a woman
with the intent of taking an insurance
claim out on her
when surprised me at the female black
widows that were doing that were
also lesbian i mean what they want a man
for
and they don't want a man you know what
i mean they want a man they could kill
him
they were crazy too well yeah like a
normal people i don't like it well
obviously
yeah like i said i don't i don't even
know i don't really like any kind of
emotional attachment there well yeah and
i don't even think like sexuality
probably played into it like i said when
you're talking about serial killers most
people think of ones with like sexual
motives yeah he did have a wife and a
kid from his very first he had a couple
of kids he ran from that
yeah which tells me he wasn't happy with
that situation
he was just always moving around
changing his name
i think it was just society at the time
he was expected to get married and have
kids so he did that
yeah he was expected to but he wasn't
happy with that he was funny he was gay
and then but he was also a serial killer
you know
yeah then he goes [ __ ] running off
messing with these boys
because i guess he thought the boys
wouldn't tell on him and
i think he may have killed him we might
have let him go
you know which would take it to kind of
like albert fish
he was in the boys too but he was into
anything though
albert fish is like he's in there the
grossest [ __ ]
we did a show about it yeah holy [ __ ]
but i think it was just
i think the boys were just like targets
of opportunity but i think that's where
his
sexuality was really lie lay yeah
boys boys probably
probably yeah yeah kevin donovan said
after he left chicago he moved to fort
worth and built another murder castle i
see i thought i knew that he went to
fort worth but i didn't know that he'd
actually
completed another castle down there um
because i don't they just kind of
skimmed over it in the documentary
so i was under the impression that he
hadn't finished it but maybe he did
yeah but like i said it you know so the
thing about it was that
so they they finally caught him the
thing about it is that he was only
convicted of what like one murder right
benjamin peitzel that was like the dude
or
you know however you pronounced his last
name who was his partner
because i love this he so him and his
partner they're doing all this insurance
fraud
and then he's like hey hey ben i have
this really great idea um
we're gonna fake we're gonna put up to
like take out a life insurance policy on
you and then i'm gonna fake your death
except he's like
psych i'm actually really gonna kill you
so he does not can't
he doesn't look really happy
[Laughter]
gay may not be the right word for it
might just be pedo
i think he was in the boys little boys
that's what i'm thinking maybe i don't
think he was in the little girls because
he didn't keep him he killed him
he put him in a [ __ ] trunk and got
him like and like i said i think he just
did that because they were in the way
yeah but it's a sexually motivated
serial killer of his
means because he did have means you know
i mean he had no money
would have kept those girls for a lot
longer think about it
yeah yeah and the only reason why they
kill them is to silence them so they can
move on they don't know where to put
them
you know but he had a place to put him
he could have kept him up there in that
castle
yeah no one would have liked that
because he had all kind of like you know
kind of incredible
and he would have talked him into
working for him or something he turned
him into little slaves and stuff
but he wasn't interested in them yeah it
really didn't you know nothing i've read
about him implies that
he was any in any way sexually motivated
on any of it it was just kind of like
everything was just very
prosaic right i guess if you want to
this if that's not a horrible
ted if ted bundy had the means
and came across those three little girls
he'd have kept him but he didn't have
the means to keep him he was too poor
yeah in order to put him but you know
what i mean you got to look at in that
context
ted bundy you'll just keep your severed
head yeah because ted bundy went for
young
went for little girls when he could when
he get when he got him i think the
youngest one you have i think was 12.
it was just like a target of opportunity
yeah if you'd given him three little
girls he'd kept him
yep probably yeah one one thing that
makes me happy
every time i hear about h.h holmes like
i said there was some rumors that he had
like faked his death and [ __ ] like that
because like i said he had done it
before
uh for insurance fraud but they're like
no they really did hang him i love
that when they hanged him uh the rope
didn't break his neck
and he just like hung there and
strangled for like 15 minutes and i was
like good surprise
[ __ ] yeah so he only got
convicted of one murder
even though they're pretty sure like um
well they knew that he did he killed
those two little girls because they
found their bodies right
and then they found another little boy
that he had killed he killed him and
like chopped him up and stuffed him up
in a chimney or something and they found
that body
but i guess they didn't have enough
proof dario brings up a good point
said [ __ ] holmes may have had a glory
hole up in the castle
think of that yeah maybe yeah holmes
glory hall
[Laughter]
i'm amazed that somebody stupid [ __ ]
i mean somebody somewhere please correct
me i mean this seems like a golden
opportunity why nobody has opened
like a haunted house type attraction
that is modeled after
holmes's murder castle you know what i
mean
you'd have to walk through it well yeah
that's what i'm saying problem is
you don't want you don't want the public
walking through something like that it
taken forever to
get through it they like to be in those
little doom buggies
where it's like a three-minute
experience you're in you're the [ __ ] out
of there trying to get them well yeah
you know like the haunted mansion at
disney was originally conceived as a
walk-through attraction
yeah they can't walk through and for
that reason they were hanging out in
there
yeah they said it it would take like
forever forever because everybody would
be like digging around you know it's
like oh let's go in here and let's go
and i'm just gonna wait here and have a
cigarette
yeah and then they'd like fart around in
there all day that's what would happen
so they were like yeah we need some way
to like
so it took them like a really long time
to like figure out like how to get
people through
it was going to be boats originally it
was supposed to be like a flooded house
the closest thing i've ever
been in that was like what you're
talking about was uh in magic mountain
in california
it was called the the magic pagoda and
it was right next to the
where the chinese restaurant was in a
big food court
and you walked in there's a giant buddha
and his [ __ ] face is talking he's
saying welcome to the [ __ ] magic
pagoda
it was [ __ ] spooky and then then you
went through it it was like a fun house
you had them yeah we had one here yeah
we have one of those here yeah it was
pretty cool maze of mirrors and then
rooms that had uh [ __ ] uh
strobe lights with a big old chinese
[ __ ] paper dragon going around the
ceiling
and uh yeah that's pretty cool that's
right i've been all about yeah and then
you look down and you see like uh
little miniature cities like you had to
walk over a little like a
like a chinese little bridge you know
little bridges and that yeah yeah i
think
and then you walked over little chinese
bridge and they had like a miniaturized
city with
little cars and lights and everything
that's how i remember it's been a long
time
we had one like that here in orlando
what the [ __ ] was the name of it was
that
[ __ ] man i know it had something to do
with wizards because it was like a
really big wizard like on the front
and uh it was kind of more it was like
that but it was like
it was more scary you know what i mean
like it was more like a haunted house
but you walked through it there was
there was kind of the thing where you
walked through with like the rotating
room and
you know i remember one where you walked
through this hallway and like the floor
would light up and there was like a
scary face under there and like [ __ ]
would pop out at you and whatnot
um god damn it why can't the name of
that place it's not there anymore
and i think like in downtown orlando for
a long time this is probably going back
[ __ ] 15 or 20 years they did have
like a haunted house
attraction like a you know just like one
of the ones that would have it universal
like at halloween like halloween horror
nights they'd have a house like that
except it was there all the time
um i never went to it though but i think
it was supposed to be like a torture
dungeon or
something like that i don't think it's
there you could walk through the magic
pagoda and imagine
in in magic mountain but that's because
it wasn't that interesting
yeah yeah i mean people wouldn't hang
out and they knew that people wouldn't
just be like
and they ended up tearing it down yeah
and something else here well yeah and i
can totally see why and like i said back
when they're working on the haunted
mansion like for
disneyland and disney world uh they
immediately saw that problem they were
because they wanted it to be walkthrough
too but then they were like yeah no
we're not
just gonna let people like dick around
in there all day because it would take
forever like
and the lines would back up yep you know
what i mean they you know what they were
gonna do at first they were gonna have
people walk through but then they were
gonna build two
exactly the same like to speed it up
inside to speed it up so like you could
go through half it was going to be
inside the same house so you didn't
actually know that there were two sides
that were just the same
but uh yeah they were good and then
finally they were just like [ __ ] it
that's not going to work we have to like
get people moving through there
i thought it was a trip that there's
more than one stretch room elevators but
there's several of them see i never knew
that either
until i like read that book about it i'm
like and they're exactly the same
yeah i've been on that ride somebody
like the disney world one i've been on
that so many times and i never
[ __ ] noticed that there were two of
them how many of them are there two
okay there are two all right in both as
far as i know i bought another book
about the history of uh
the haunted mansion but i haven't got to
read it yet i believe for some reason
i'm fascinated by that
he remembers the magic pagoda yeah magic
pagoda
he looked 80s as [ __ ] it was kind of
cool like chinese fake 80s
a bunch of nina a bunch of neon ships
really that would have been right up my
alley look like a chinese restaurant on
acid
see that i've been right now it's like a
fun house that's one of my uh
that's one of my aesthetics i like that
kind of yeah
you just go through the glass and you go
through the maze of mirrors then all of
a sudden one of the mirrors would light
up and you could see through it was like
a two-way mirror
and behind it would be like a big
monster going it looked like
the [ __ ] mogatu from [ __ ] star
trek
fighting with a giant agoran with a
giant [ __ ]
snake that had a human head on it okay
well like something from another
like something from thailand or
something that's pretty scary yeah it's
supposed to be kind of scary i think it
had a human head on it on the end of the
snake
thailand's got some like scary [ __ ]
thailand thing like hey i'm a witch and
my head pops off during the night with
all the [ __ ] entrails dragging down
and it comes out i think it was a buddha
[ __ ] up i think it was a buddha fight
and it's been so long man
it was it was cheap you know it was big
but it was like buddha versus human head
snake
the next sci-fi original film
buddha versus big snake big hand snake
yeah big head snake in the make a whole
[ __ ] movie based on that [ __ ]
well yeah we need to do that [ __ ] well
look we'll we'll look one shows up
we'll look on 2b later and then it'll
already be there
and it's the kaiju yeah you know what i
mean
rodan shows up
i mean why not monster zero shows up why
not yeah godzilla
yeah throw all the [ __ ] in there yeah
gamer
gamer name size but it's the same size
as the mall
be like big man japan yeah he fights
alongside ultraman
yeah and jet jaguar yeah
you got it see that now i want to see
this movie we need to make it
all right all right we done talking
about this yeah all right
so like i said this is on amazon prime
it's on to be it's free
um like i said the narration's good but
just don't pay attention to the
visuals because it's it's uh pretty
cheap like like i said i could probably
do better for
for a hundred dollars but you know i'm
just i don't want to be too much of it
it had a dragon yeah it did have a
dragon had a chinese dragon that went
around on the ceiling on a track in a
room that had a big strobe light people
out there strobing
you you could tell some of the kids were
on acid going to magic mountain on acid
they'd be in the struggle well yeah look
like this is back in the day when a
strobe light would trip people out
wow and then they had a chinese paper
dragon it was like one that you know the
guys would wear in the parades it was
like that
and it's going around on the ceiling
that's cool see i've never been all into
that
yeah like i said i i love i love all
that real like
that old like chin like 70s 80s chinese
restaurant
yes it was like i mean i like that
almost as much as i like old
western whorehouse i also like that as
well
they probably tore that [ __ ] down
because they said that she was
culturally insensitive
because they had [ __ ] buddha [ __ ]
talking and [ __ ] [ __ ] although there
were many buddhas buddha just means wise
man they you know
the buddhism had well they probably tore
it down because nobody went there
anymore because it was just
what it was what it was just saying i
don't think they'd do it today
it what it was it was just wasn't it
wasn't that impressive
i mean it's not the [ __ ] that they have
right look at the [ __ ] they have now
that's why the one that we
had which was just had which just like a
wizard and whatnot
um you know that closed years and years
ago just because
it was cool when you were a kid but it's
like after they opened
like big theme parks and [ __ ] like that
people nobody went to it anymore
yeah you know what i mean all right so
uh
that'll that'll do it for this today
right you didn't have anything else you
had to talk about okay
so it's tuesday right yeah i think so
all right so uh tomorrow night's party
stream
yeah that's right wednesday night we
don't know what we're gonna talk about
something
gotta get ready for that [ __ ] yeah you
gotta you gotta start getting ready for
it now you've got
24 hours like psych yourself up for it
yeah getting ready for it it'll be all
right just get some sleep and
make sure you have the right kind of
booze we got to make sure we got the
booze correct and all that other kind of
stuff we'll have to run the party lights
and hope it doesn't crash the stream
we may have to say [ __ ] the party like
we may have to say [ __ ] the price
because you noticed it hasn't done it
since i stopped that yeah i'm
it maybe it was that maybe i mean that's
like an easy problem to solve
yeah all right so uh we will see you
guys tomorrow evening at 5 00 pm
eastern standard time talking about
whatever it is we're gonna talk about
and uh thanks everybody for dropping by
as always we'll see you later
bye